Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor Greene is in a
very safe Republican district in Georgia as
a radical Trumpist member of the House of
Representatives.
But for the first time, she spent more money
than she raised, and her Democratic challenger
raised more money than she did.
Now, I don't want to give anybody false hope
because she is in a very red district, but
this is not particularly good news for her.
Democratic challenger outraised Marjorie Taylor
Greene in Georgia.
You really love to see this.
Democrat Marcus Flowers outraised Greene in
the first three months of 2022, according
to his latest federal filings.
Flowers, an army veteran and former military
contractor, pulled in more than $2.4 million
in the first quarter of 2022, dwarfing says
the Hill.
The fundraising haul of Greene, who raised
under $1.1 million in the exact same time
span.
Now, importantly, not only is it a very safe
Republican district, Flowers is behind Greene
in cash on hand.
The latest filings with the FEC show Greene
has three million in the bank.
Flowers has one point nine million.
And overall, Greene has raised about 8.4 million
for her reelection.
Flowers is behind, but not super far, at 7.1
million for his campaign.
So far, unseating Greene is likely to be an
uphill battle for any Democrat.
That is absolutely true.
But this may be a sign that there is an appetite.
For rejecting radical, extremist, cartoonish,
pathetic pond scum, Trumpism, which is what
Marjorie Taylor Greene represents.
Yahoo News reporting.
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Greene's campaign
committee goes into the red for the first
time, clocking up a fundraising deficit totaling
three hundred and fourteen thousand dollars.
Marjorie Taylor Greene Campaign Committee
reported its first net loss since she was
elected.
It spent one point thirty eight million in
the first quarter of 2022 and banked 1.6 million
in donations.
The 1.06 was rounded to one point one in the
previous article.
The spending included $140000 for her security
and a retainer fee to Trump lawyer John Eastman.
That's that wacky guy who's like, Yeah, Mike
Pence, just overturn the entire thing.
So again, the district is depending on where
you look 30 points in favor of a Republican.
It might only be 20.
It might be 40.
It depends where you look, but it is a really,
really heavy Republican district.
I don't know how flowers wins, but this could
be a good sign.
And it's also important to understand that
the incumbent effect is very real.
And so even with the same fundraising, you
would probably expect Greene to win because
the incumbency effect is very real.
But that's also what makes the fundraising
numbers even more notable for a non-incumbent
in such a red district to be equally or even
outraising.
The incumbent Republican says a lot.
Now, of course, a lot of that money is coming
from out of the district.
Tonight, a big shock that there are people
outside of that Georgia district who would
love to see Marjorie Taylor Greene removed
because she's such a lunatic and just holding
the seat gives her an advantage.
And this is not likely the district.
This is not likely to be a bellwether district
in November.
There are others that are more likely to be
what bellwether districts were going to talk
about them.
But if we want to find something good here,
it's that this is a sort of celebrity Republican
congresswoman in a very red seat.
And she lost net money spent more than she
took in in the first quarter of 2022.
And her opponent, who is not particularly
well known, at least wasn't before this election
started, is able to keep up in fundraising.
It's a great thing it would be great to knock
her out.
I'm not counting him out, but we just have
to be realistic.
It's an insanely Republican skewed district.
We'll take a quick break and be back after
this with with much
more for you.